JAMES MULCAHY: Hey, guys.
What's up?
I'm James Mulcahy.
I'm the Lead Video Producer at
Zagat, which is, as you know,
the restaurant,
brand, and guidebook.
So they called me in
to interview Gina, who
is a author of the
"Skinnytaste Cookbook,"
and she publishes recipes
at the Skinnytaste blog,
Skinnytaste.com.
GINA HOMOLKA: Mm-hmm.
And you probably saw some of her
recipes today at Hemispheres.
What did you make today,
or what were the recipes?
GINA HOMOLKA: The
Buttermilk Fried Chicken,
the Sriracha Salmon,
the Brussels Sprouts
with Prosciutto.
What else was there?
FEMALE SPEAKER: The farroto.
GINA HOMOLKA: The
Carrot Farroto.
FEMALE SPEAKER: The Greek salad.
GINA HOLMOKA: Yes,
the chickpea salad.
JAMES MULCAHY: There should
be a tasting with the talk
while we eat it--
GINA HOMOLKA: Yeah, we should.
JAMES MULCAHY: --as we discuss.
FEMALE SPEAKER: The carne asada.
GINA HOMOLKA: Oh,
the carne asada.
Yeah, that was
Ashley's favorite.
JAMES MULCAHY: So I'm curious
just being from Zagat,
I think an easy place to
start is with restaurants.
I always ask this
question to everyone
I meet, what's your favorite?
Where do you go in New York?
GINA HOMOLKA: Yeah.
So I always have a
hard time with this
because I feel like I don't
really have a favorite.
Every day it might be
a different favorite.
But we were just
talking about this now
and I was saying I love Spice
Market in the Meatpacking
District.
So today I'm going to
go with that answer.
JAMES MULCAHY: That's good.
You should come back
to Google cafeteria.
They actually do some
great Indian food.
GINA HOMOLKA: I love Indian.
JAMES MULCAHY: The
lines are always
like down the corridor
for Indian food days.
GINA HOMOLKA: Yeah, definitely.
I would definitely
come back for that.
You let me know.
JAMES MULCAHY: We will.
We will.
Cool.
Let's talk about "Skinnytaste."
I know you started
out as a blogger,
and it's just you, right,
just writing a blog.
How did that begin,
and did you ever
think it would get
to this point where
there's these projections
of a book behind us where--
GINA HOMOLKA: No.
This whole thing is so surreal,
because I started as a photo
retoucher, and I was a graphic
designer, and I started a blog.
I was trying to lose
weight for my wedding
and I couldn't find
anything to make online.
I was Googling recipes for--
Weight Watcher-friendly
recipes, and everything I
found was really processed,
the sites were poorly designed.
So I decided, well, let me just
try and see if I could do this.
And I just started a blog.
I was experimenting
with my own recipes
that I was making at
home because I've always
loved cooking.
And I started sharing
it out in this blog,
never realizing that people
would try the recipes
and comment and start giving
me all this great feedback.
And they start losing weight and
telling me about their weight
loss stories.
And it just inspired
me to keep going.
So this whole thing
has been a crazy ride.
JAMES MULCAHY:
Was there a moment
when you were blogging in the
very beginning where you said,
oh, my god.
This could be a career for me,
this could be a path forward.
Like did you get
that one comment
that was like the aha moment?
GINA HOMOLKA: So when
I started blogging,
I didn't do it to
quit my career,
because I loved being a retouch
and I loved working in the city
and working in a creative space.
I think it was January
and my traffic spiked.
It doubled overnight.
And my advertiser
that was working
with me called me and
said, what are you doing?
Are you working with a team?
Like what's going on?
They were trying
to figure out why
I'm getting so much traffic.
And I think that moment said,
wow, I could make a career out
of this.
But I didn't leave my
job yet because I really
loved working as a retoucher
and I was kind of afraid to just
leave during a recession.
So it wasn't until I
had my baby Madison--
now she's five-- that I actually
left and made it full-time.
JAMES MULCAHY:
Was there a moment
when you said, OK, I know
I can do this full-time?
GINA HOMOLKA: Yeah.
Well, I probably knew I
could have done it full-time
when I had my
daughter, and it was
my husband who actually
had to push me and tell me,
why are you working?
You're doing so
great with this blog.
You could do this at
home and raise Madison.
And I kind of needed
him to make that push.
But I think that was-- just
seeing the revenue that
was coming from the blog, I
knew I could make it full-time.
JAMES MULCAHY: That's cool.
So when you first
started experimenting
with these recipes,
was there something
missing in other recipes
that you found when
you started Googling around?
What did you try to add when
you started the site to kind
of this skinny conversation?
GINA HOMOLKA: So when I
first Googled recipes--
I was doing Weight
Watchers because I
was trying to lose weight--
everything was very processed.
So it was like take a
can of Campbell's Soup
and mix it with another
ingredient and that's dinner.
Now, I always liked cooking
and I had a nine-year-old
and she's picky, and my
fiance was very picky.
So I knew I couldn't
make that for them.
They would not be OK with it.
So I just started
taking my recipes
that they loved
and I just started
playing around with them
and making them lighter
and getting their thumbs
up or their thumbs down,
and that's how I started.
They critiqued everything.
They still do.
JAMES MULCAHY: Right.
It's a pretty good
job, I imagine.
GINA HOMOLKA: Yes.
Yes.
JAMES MULCAHY: So
did they lose weight
when they were critiquing?
I know you told me
about your aunt, right?
GINA HOMOLKA: Yeah.
So when I was doing the
cookbook, I, for the first time
used a recipe
tester to make sure
that all the recipes
were accurately written,
and she worked with
me for an entire year.
And I had so much food
for my blog and the book
from testing that I wound up
eating lunch with her every day
and then I would give her dinner
to take home for her family.
We had too much food and I
don't like throwing out food.
So she started losing weight,
and every month I would see her
and she'd be like look,
my pants are really loose.
And for the entire year she went
from a size 14 to a size four.
And we thought maybe she was
sick, she went to the doctor.
And the doctor was
like you're perfect.
You're cholesterol's great.
Like what are you doing?
And she's like you have
to go Skinnytaste.com.
And I ask her all the
time, so what is it
that you did different?
And she's like you just taught
me how to cook different.
I didn't realize that I
didn't need all that oil,
and I started trying things
that I would have never eaten
before, like spaghetti
squash or all these things
that she's never tried
before and she was now
eating and liking, and
her family was eating.
And now she's still a size
four and she works out.
She goes to the gym.
So she's completely
changed her life.
JAMES MULCAHY:
That's amazing you
get a doctor to kind of
write the stamp of approval,
right, for the website.
GINA HOMOLKA: I loved it
because I always got emails
from people telling me
about their weight loss,
but I never actually met people.
So to actually see the
transition for the whole year,
it was an incredible thing.
JAMES MULCAHY: Yes.
I imagine you've developed kind
of a following over the years
from the site that brought
you to this cookbook.
What is it like to
interact with these people?
GINA HOMOLKA: So that's my
favorite part of blogging.
When I first started blogging,
getting their comments
is what made me addicted to it.
And when they started telling
me that I'm making a difference
and I'm helping them with
their weight loss journey,
that's what made me
continue doing it.
It was never about making it
a career, about the money.
I felt like I had to
help these people.
Like I like helping people and
I like doing things for people.
So it's the most gratifying
feeling in the world.
When I wake up some days,
I'm having a bad day
and I'll check my comments
or an email and somebody
sends me this beautiful email
that they used to be a diabetic
and now they're
diabetes is all clear
and they're losing
weight, or they're
starting to cook healthy
for their family.
Like that makes me feel so good.
So I know I'm making a
difference in people's lives.
JAMES MULCAHY: So yeah,
what's the secret then?
You're getting
these emails, people
are clearly having effects.
Do you have a mantra
or kind of an idiom
that you're working in?
What do people learn when
they come to your site?
GINA HOMOLKA: I think
it's just about how
to balance your meals.
So I will use
leaner cuts of meat.
I'll use whole grains.
I'll make sure that the
portions are correct.
When I'm using grains I'll
increase the vegetables
so that you're getting
a decent portion.
Obviously, you don't want to
be hungry just to lose weight.
So I make sure that all the
portions are always filling.
And just adding so much
flavor, seasonings, fresh herbs
is really just
what I like to do.
JAMES MULCAHY: Is it
more about learning
how to change your lifestyle--
GINA HOMOLKA: It is.
JAMES MULCAHY: --to
change your recipes?
GINA HOMOLKA: I
feel like anybody
could take their favorite
recipe and make it lighter.
So it's not about not being
able to eat the foods you love.
It's about taking
the foods you love
and learning how
to recreate them
so that you could still eat
them, just in a lighter way.
JAMES MULCAHY: Is
there a few cuisines
that this works well with, or do
you just go all over the place?
GINA HOMOLKA: Everything.
I love all kinds of cuisines.
JAMES MULCAHY: So you can
go to the Spice Market
across the street and
recreate the menu--
GINA HOMOLKA: Absolutely.
JAMES MULCAHY: make
it a little skinnier.
GINA HOMOLKA: That's
what I love doing, yes.
JAMES MULCAHY:
Yeah, that's good.
I'm curious because I think a
lot of people-- maybe myself
included-- don't necessarily
want to commit to a diet
or making all these recipes.
Do you have three
or four easy tips
that you can change right
away, like small things that
would make a big difference?
GINA HOMOLKA: Yeah.
If you drink soda, I would say
eliminate that immediately.
JAMES MULCAHY:
[LAUGH] Event diet?
GINA HOMOLKA: Yes,
especially diet
because it's all processed.
So eliminating sodas is a first.
And I would say
drink lots of water
or seltzer-- my
husband likes seltzer.
Eliminating processed foods.
Eat clean.
I don't use fat-free ingredients
because they're so processed,
and you wind up, I feel like,
gaining weight from them.
And they're not healthy.
So I say eliminating
all the processed junk.
And a third would I
would say exercise.
I try to exercise three
or four times a week.
So just having a balance.
JAMES MULCAHY: Good.
I'm glad you didn't
say stop drinking beer.
GINA HOMOLKA: No.
I like My wine, so I do have
my occasional glass of wine.
JAMES MULCAHY: That's good.
And what about the cookbook?
So how did you jump from
blogging to publishing?
GINA HOMOLKA: So I was getting
requests from the Skinnytaste
fans, and they kept
asking me daily,
emailing me on Facebook, on
Twitter, everywhere possible,
so please come out
with a cookbook.
So I was like, all right,
I want to give them
the cookbook because
I'm a people pleaser
and I want to give
people what they want.
And then I started getting
approached by publishers,
so I knew, all right, there's
a possibility to do this.
And then I got an
agent and started
working with Clarkson Potter.
JAMES MULCAHY: That's awesome.
Clarkson Potter, they do a
lot of good food titles there.
GINA HOMOLKA: They
do great books.
JAMES MULCAHY: So what
was that like as opposed
to sitting on a computer
and publishing a blog post?
What was the cookbook
process like?
GINA HOMOLKA:
Completely different,
because I feel like
in the beginning
it took me a long time
to come up with a recipe.
I just felt like with a
book it was so important
and it had to sit on a shelf.
So I really struggled
with the first recipe.
And then when I realized wow,
for me to meet my deadline
I have to complete four a week.
So then I started
getting cranking
and was like, OK,
I could do this.
But it was different
also because I was still
creating content for my
blog, so there was just a lot
of coming up with new recipes.
But there was just that
importance of people
are paying for this,
as opposed to they
can get recipes for
free on my blog.
So that was probably
the difference.
JAMES MULCAHY: So it's not
just a collection of recipes
that people can find online.
You have to get the book or
take the books on your seats
to get those specific recipes.
GINA HOMOLKA: Right.
There's 25 from the blog,
125 that are brand new.
JAMES MULCAHY: So how do you
come up with that many recipes?
GINA HOMOLKA: I'm always
thinking about food.
I'll be at the gym
talking to my girlfriend
and we're talking about food.
Like we're always
talking about food.
I'm always thinking about it.
I'm always thinking of how
to make something lighter,
or what's a great swap to
make something different.
So I get inspired
when I go out to eat.
I love going out to
eat for that reason.
I come up with really great
ideas from a great fish
in a great restaurant.
Sometimes I get people that
send me requests for makeovers,
and those are usually some
of my most popular recipes.
JAMES MULCAHY: Like a green
bean casserole, but healthy?
GINA HOMOLKA: Yeah.
I've done that for the blog.
JAMES MULCAHY: I actually
had that over the holidays,
and why is anyone
eating this anymore?
GINA HOMOLKA: Right, exactly.
JAMES MULCAHY: Cream
of mushroom soup.
GINA HOMOLKA: Some of
my most popular recipes
that are actually in the
book are makeovers, yeah.
JAMES MULCAHY: Yeah,
that's exciting.
I mean I think it must be
really hard to just like--
do you ever get tired?
You ever just say I don't
want to make anymore recipes?
GINA HOMOLKA: I
mean there are days
that I may not feel
like cooking, because I
cook every day.
But I give myself a break.
On the weekends I'll
go out to dinner.
It's where I get my inspiration.
But I love going
out to dinner, and I
feel like it's all balanced.
Like I eat really good
during the week and I know
I'm cooking good.
So I allow myself a
treat on the weekends.
JAMES MULCAHY: Yeah,
so you have that moment
and you're like I
just want a burger.
I just want fries.
That's allowed.
GINA HOMOLKA: Yeah.
It's usually not
what I'm craving,
and not the fries or the burger.
I usually crave more like--
JAMES MULCAHY: We're very
different people, clearly.
GINA HOMOLKA: Yeah.
I'm probably craving a great
pasta dish or something.
Yeah.
JAMES MULCAHY: Do you
have any guilty pleasures?
GINA HOMOLKA: I would say wine.
JAMES MULCAHY: There's nothing
to be guilty about there.
GINA HOMOLKA: Is that bad?
JAMES MULCAHY: Wine.
You don't just like stuff
your face with Oreos?
GINA HOMOLKA: No.
I don't like Oreos.
I don't like sweets, really.
So yeah, no.
Maybe banana pie, and I haven't
had that in a long time.
So no, I don't really-- the
sweets don't really bother me.
JAMES MULCAHY: Do you feel
like your palate has changed
going through this process
from when you first
started-- what you thought
tasted good to today?
GINA HOMOLKA: I feel like
that happens all the time.
But I grew up with parents that
cooked everything from scratch.
And they are both-- one is from
South America and one's Czech.
So I grew up with a lot
of diverse cuisines,
and I've always liked
trying new things.
So I have a diverse
palate and I enjoy trying
all different kinds of foods.
JAMES MULCAHY: And
when you started
maybe you thought
you liked sweets more
and now you just want the cal.
Because I've noticed
eating out a lot
that I only can eat
restaurant food now because I
eat it all the time, which
that's not a good thing.
GINA HOMOLKA: Right.
I guess I've probably grown
to like things that I didn't
before just out of making them.
Or I will take an ingredient
that I may not love and figure
out a way to make it delicious.
JAMES MULCAHY: What
about your kids?
How do they react
to these recipes,
and do you have to make kind
of modifications for them
to make it maybe a little
bit more kid friendly?
GINA HOMOLKA: I never
cook separate meals
for my kids and myself.
Like my daughter Madison who's
five loves Brussels sprouts
raw, shaved, a salad.
She makes her own
salad and she asks
me like when I'm
in the supermarket
and I call my husband,
do we need anything?
She's like make sure you
buy Brussels sprouts, which
is the strangest thing.
Because I feel like she grew
up with me cooking and chopping
and she was tasting all my
raw, like all my vegetables
when it was in the rough state.
So she tries everything.
She doesn't like everything, but
she will always try everything.
JAMES MULCAHY: But you don't
sneak them cookies or whatever
the unhealthy dishes would be?
GINA HOMOLKA: You
know they don't really
think they're eating Skinny.
They just know they're
eating home-cooked meals
that their mom makes
for them and they love.
So yeah.
JAMES MULCAHY: I think
it's really weird.
I mean this generation
of kids that
is growing up on whole
foods and growing up
on all these natural organic.
Like what's next for them?
Because I remember
the first time
I had an actually good Brussels
sprout that wasn't from a can.
GINA HOMOLKA: Right.
JAMES MULCAHY: This is amazing.
But they all are
growing up on this.
Are they going to go
back, the reverse,
be like I just
want Wonder bread?
GINA HOMOLKA: You know, I feel
like there's still a long way
to go.
My daughter likes
Brussels sprouts,
but in school I hear from the
teachers that most of the kids
don't like healthy food.
So I feel like there's
still-- they're not there yet.
JAMES MULCAHY: Well,
I think probably
because they healthy
food that they're eating
is not like this healthy food.
GINA HOMOLKA: Right.
JAMES MULCAHY: It's kind of
like still processed-ish.
GINA HOMOLKA: Right.
I mean kids' palates,
they're all different,
and some kids are very picky.
But I think it's
also important not
to cook separate
meals for your kids,
like macaroni and
cheese and pizza when
you're cooking something else.
I just say cook what
you're cooking for dinner
and let them try a
little bit of everything.
And if she doesn't eat
the entire plate, it's OK.
At least she tries it.
I always make her
taste-- at least
take one bite of
something if she tells me
she doesn't want it.
And then she usually
winds up liking it.
JAMES MULCAHY: I think they
would really like the Google
cafeteria as well.
There's always lots of kelp--
GINA HOLMOKA: Oh, forget it.
JAMES MULCAHY:
Cauliflower's everywhere.
GINA HOMOLKA: She would go
crazy in the raw bar, I think.
She likes raw vegetables.
JAMES MULCAHY: So what
do you hope people
will get out of your cookbook?
Is it a resource to
"The Joy of Cooking"
that should be used every day?
Is it kind of a starter
to a diet when you start,
I'm going to go buy
that and try to do this?
GINA HOMOLKA: I hope
I could inspire people
to start cooking a
little healthier,
just to give them a little hope.
Like if they're
trying to lose weight,
they don't feel like they
have to eat cardboard.
That they could make a meal for
the entire family and everyone
will enjoy it.
Or even for people that
don't know how to cook.
It hopefully will show
people that it's not hard.
It's really simple.
I think my recipes are
all really easy to follow.
I use ingredients that you could
find in a local supermarket.
So if I can just inspire
somebody, then I did my job.
JAMES MULCAHY: Do you
think you're a chef?
GINA HOMOLKA: I don't
call myself a chef.
I'm a home cook.
JAMES MULCAHY: What's
the difference there?
GINA HOMOLKA: I feel like a
chef has culinary training,
and I don't know all
those fancy techniques.
I think that's why
maybe I'm relatable,
because I'm making a quick
dinner under 30 minutes
that my husband likes,
my daughter likes.
That's my goal.
I don't know how to
cook for a restaurant.
I can't cook for 80.
So I think there's a
big difference there.
JAMES MULCAHY: Yeah.
I think maybe the art is the
same, but the kind of execution
is different.
GINA HOMOLKA: Right.
And I'm learning as I go.
I'm always learning,
which is really fun.
JAMES MULCAHY: So being a person
who goes out to restaurants
all the time, you say
you get your inspiration
from restaurant meals
and things like that.
When I'm looking at the
menu at the restaurant,
are there certain things I
should kind of avoid and say
I'm going to be a little
bit better tonight,
and certain things that are
oh, I should go for that.
GINA HOMOLKA: I mean if you're
trying to have a good day,
I would say avoid the
bread basket probably.
Stick with avoid anything fried
and have the grilled fish.
But when I go out
to dinner, I usually
order whatever is the special,
whatever appeals to me,
and maybe I just won't
eat the whole thing.
I'll take half home
or I'll share it.
Like I love trying a new dish
so I can get the inspiration
to recreate it, you know?
JAMES MULCAHY: Yeah, people
who I've really talked to
and say they have a
really good diet success,
it's always portion
control seems to be a big--
GINA HOMOLKA: Absolutely.
JAMES MULCAHY: --part of that.
Is that taken into
account in your recipes?
GINA HOMOLKA: Yes.
All my recipes have
the nutritional values
and the portion control
all printed in the book.
And I measure
everything precisely
so that people know
what their portions are.
JAMES MULCAHY: I've
tried to trick myself
by getting the smaller dish.
It never works.
I just kind of fill it up twice.
That's a myth, at least for me.
What about social media?
Because I know you started
your blog and that was in 2008?
2006?
GINA HOMOLKA: 2007.
JAMES MULCAHY: 2007.
So that was like pre-Instagram,
pre-Twitter and pre
all of that.
How has that changed what
you do and how does it
help what you do?
GINA HOMOLKA: I think it
definitely helped what I do,
because most of my traffic
comes from social media.
I think Google's my number
one source of traffic,
and number two is social media.
So it's huge.
I mean some people
start new blogs
and are found on social media.
So I think I only
helps, not hurts.
I mean Instagram
I'm addicted to.
And I like to share
what I'm doing
on a daily basis-- my recipes,
but also my kids, Google.
Whatever I'm doing.
It's just like an
extension of my blog.
JAMES MULCAHY: So yay or nay at
the restaurant with your phone
on the dish, on the table.
GINA HOMOLKA: Yay.
JAMES MULCAHY: That's allowed?
GINA HOMOLKA: I do
that, absolutely.
JAMES MULCAHY: I
definitely do that.
I'm the guy who has one
phone here and a phone
with a flashlight there.
So I get it right.
GINA HOMOLKA: I don't think
I'd go to a restaurant that
didn't let me take pictures.
JAMES MULCAHY: Do you think
if you started your blog today
in this more digital age where
everyone's a little bit more
dialed in, everyone is updating
Instagram all the time,
do you think you would have
found the same path to success?
GINA HOMOLKA: I think it's
a lot harder for people
that are starting blogs today.
There's just so many.
There are millions
of blogs out there.
You really have to do something
that sets yourself apart,
whether it's your photography
or a different type of niche.
But it's definitely
more challenging today.
JAMES MULCAHY: Yeah, I think
it's a lot more saturated.
If you're going to give
advice to someone who's
thinking about wanting
to start a blog
and wanting to write about
food or get on social media
and be a food person, what
advice would you give them?
GINA HOMOLKA: I would say just
be authentic, be yourself.
Don't try to copy
somebody else's idea
and try to do what
they're doing.
Everybody's unique and you
have something unique to bring.
So I would say focus on what's
different about yourself.
And also, really learn
how to use a camera,
because the photography is the
most important part of being
found on social media, or
even somebody trying a recipe.
If it looks good,
they'll make it.
JAMES MULCAHY: To see food
is such a visual thing--
GINA HOMOLKA: It really is.
JAMES MULCAHY: --and
people want to see--
GINA HOMOLKA: They
eat with their eyes.
JAMES MULCAHY: --what's
in front of them for sure.
GINA HOMOLKA: Yeah.
JAMES MULCAHY: I think just
being a blogger myself, I
think the advice I would give is
don't get bummed if it doesn't
take off right away.
GINA HOMOLKA: Oh yeah.
JAMES MULCAHY: It took
a long time for you
to get to this point.
GINA HOMOLKA: If I would
have done this actually make
a career out of it I
would have given up,
because I wasn't
getting much traffic.
I was happy when I got
50 followers a month.
It was happy, but I
really just did it
because I found it enjoyable.
I liked getting
comments from people,
and people were trying my
recipes and giving me feedback.
So I did it because
I really thought
it was-- I was addicted to it.
It wasn't really
about the income.
JAMES MULCAHY: But now you have
to create content all the time.
GINA HOMOLKA: All the time.
JAMES MULCAHY: Does it
become swimmer or die
when you get to this level?
GINA HOMOLKA: I mean there
are weeks that I make things,
or I should say it
I could have a week
that nothing turns
out right and I'm
like what am I going to post?
This is terrible.
They don't always come
out great the first time.
I usually have to experiment,
especially when I'm baking
and I'm swapping
butter for avocados.
The crazy things I do.
Yeah, they don't always work.
What was the question?
JAMES MULCAHY: You
know, social media.
GINA HOMOLKA: Yeah.
So yeah, I don't remember.
JAMES MULCAHY: I'm curious what
you do now to the recipes that
don't work now?
GINA HOMOLKA: Oh, I throw
them in the garbage.
JAMES MULCAHY: No,
you should have
kind of like a Tumblr account
that have those bad recipes.
GINA HOMOLKA: Well, the
other day I actually
Instagramed a soup
that came out awful,
and I was just so mad
because I spent hours on it.
And I Instagramed.
I'm like this was a fail.
And people are like so thank
you for letting us know
that that happens to you too.
But then people kept
asking me for the recipe.
I'm like, but it's bad.
I'm telling you, you
don't want the recipe.
Or sometimes I'll be
at my brother's house,
and he makes a dish
that's not light.
And they're like can you
give us the recipe anyway?
So I'm like I don't know
where I'm going to do that.
JAMES MULCAHY: So you
do all this cooking
in your home kitchen.
GINA HOMOLKA: I do.
JAMES MULCAHY: And
is it a nice kitchen?
GINA HOMOLKA: No.
JAMES MULCAHY: I have
my little apartment
kitchen's like this big.
GINA HOMOLKA: There's
nothing nice about it, no.
I never take pictures
of my kitchen.
I never redid the kitchen
from when I first moved in,
and it was always my goal.
And then when I
started blogging,
I couldn't, because then
I'd have no kitchen.
So we actually
bought a new house
and we're going to make a
nice kitchen in that house.
But right now, no, the
kitchen's not pretty.
JAMES MULCAHY: I
betcha you end up
missing the not pretty kitchen.
GINA HOMOLKA: The counters
are mauve, like ugh.
There's nothing pretty about it.
JAMES MULCAHY: [LAUGH] Mauve.
I haven't heard that word since
I was using crayons I think.
GINA HOMOLKA: It's not pretty.
JAMES MULCAHY: Home
cooks, I'm sure there's
some here listening along.
What are the essential
things that they
have to have in their
kitchen to do this?
Both ingredients and kind of
tools to make these things?
GINA HOMOLKA: Well,
the ingredients, I
feel like having
all your dried herbs
and spices-- spices
and herbs are something
like you're going to spend a
lot of money in the beginning,
but they're going to
last you a long time.
So having that on hand.
And then as far as
cooking appliances,
really good nonstick
pans, a really good knife,
a wooden cutting board.
Those are essentials that
you really need to start.
JAMES MULCAHY: Right,
the kind of very basics--
GINA HOMOLKA: Really basics.
JAMES MULCAHY: that maybe
people take for granted.
GINA HOMOLKA: If you want to get
fancy, slow cooker, spiralizer.
I love my spiralizer--
yeah-- to make Zoodles,
which are zucchini noodles.
Yeah, I mean you could
have a ton of gadgets,
but to start with, you
don't really need a lot.
JAMES MULCAHY: So I think a lot
of the success of the program
for you has been just eating
with your family, too.
GINA HOMOLKA: Oh yeah.
JAMES MULCAHY: And I think
that's time is what you need,
right?
GINA HOMOLKA: Right.
Absolutely.
I mean I try to always
make the recipes quick,
because I don't really-- I
didn't have a lot of time
when I started.
I would work
full-time in the city.
You know, rush
home, cook a meal,
try to beat the light
because you have to shoot
your photos in natural light.
So I would tell my
family to hold on,
I just have to take a picture.
I'd shoot my plate and
they would wait for me--
they'd get cold food.
And again, I lost
my train of thought.
JAMES MULCAHY: No, just kind
of like being able to have
a family there to cook for--
GINA HOMOLKA: Oh yeah.
JAMES MULCAHY:
--just seems to be--
GINA HOMOLKA: Right.
I don't think I
would have started
a blog if I didn't have that.
I feel like they were my
inspiration why I started it.
JAMES MULCAHY: Yeah, yeah.
And I think the family
dinner is a good way.
Because I think a lot
of us Googlers probably
are a little bit more
on the go and crazed,
like running around.
GINA HOMOLKA: Right.
JAMES MULCAHY: So for
the delivery types
and don't have this time,
do you have any advice?
GINA HOMOLKA: Yeah.
Get a slow cooker.
I mean like there's
nothing easier
than throwing in
ingredients in the morning,
going to work, and come
home and dinner's ready.
The slow cooker is
your best friend.
Also, on the days
off, you could make
two, three batches of different
soups and then freeze them.
Put them in portion controlled,
freezer-friendly containers
and label them.
And then you have your
own freezer-friendly meals
for lunch, if you want to reheat
them, or for another dinner.
So that's a really great
way to do it and save time--
JAMES MULCAHY: Cook in batches.
GINA HOMOLKA: when you're busy.
Yeah.
JAMES MULCAHY: Yeah,
that's good advice.
And working out, I know you said
that was on your list of three
essential things.
What do you do?
GINA HOMOLKA: I like to do
strength training and cardio.
Nothing fancy.
I do treadmill, elliptical,
and just weights.
JAMES MULCAHY: So you don't
need to go to P90X or CrossFit
or all that pretty stuff.
GINA HOMOLKA: No, I
don't do any of that.
No.
I'm not that strong.
JAMES MULCAHY: Right.
[LAUGHTER]
But it is an essential part of--
GINA HOMOLKA: I feel like
it's good for your soul,
but it also, there's
a balance and I
feel better when I
work out, but I also
feel like it tones me and you
look better by working out.
So absolutely.
JAMES MULCAHY: That's
something I always
feel about when people
talk about diet, people say
oh, a diet.
I want to lose this
much weight by this day.
But to really make it successful
it's more of a lifestyle,
right?
GINA HOMOLKA: Absolutely.
JAMES MULCAHY: Make it like
a lifelong commitment that--
GINA HOMOLKA: Absolutely.
JAMES MULCAHY:
--you have to make.
GINA HOMOLKA: You don't put
on the weight in two months.
You can't expect to
lose it in two months.
I feel like you have to just
make small changes that you
can stick with long term.
I don't believe in
eliminating entire food groups
from your diet to lose weight.
Like I did no carbs
before I started blogging
and I was really unsuccessful
at it, because I craved
pasta and I craved bread.
And I would always lose
weight, but then I'd
gain it all right back because I
would start eating pasta again.
So I think just having
everything in moderation.
JAMES MULCAHY: Yeah,
even moderation.
GINA HOMOLKA: Yes.
Moderation is key.
JAMES MULCAHY: Well, it's
funny you mentioned no carbs.
So I want to ask you about a
few of the diet crazes that
are out there these days.
So you said no carbs.
You just want pasta too much.
GINA HOMOLKA: Right.
JAMES MULCAHY: Who
doesn't like carbs.
GINA HOMOLKA: I'll do
low carb, but I'll still
have my pasta days.
So yeah.
JAMES MULCAHY: Right, so you're
able to cheat a little bit.
GINA HOMOLKA: I just
kind of balance.
If I have a low carb day,
I'll have a pasta for dinner
that night.
JAMES MULCAHY: All
right, what about
have you heard about this bone
broth that people are doing?
GINA HOMOLKA: No.
JAMES MULCAHY: I just
heard about this.
It's these chefs in New York
are now basically making
kind of pasta broth that they
would usually make soup with.
But they're just serving
the broth in a coffee cup,
and apparently this is
supposed to help you
be nourished and lose weight.
GINA HOMOLKA: I don't know.
There's no solid foods involved.
JAMES MULCAHY: I guess so.
GINA HOMOLKA: A liquid diet.
I don't think I can do that.
FEMALE SPEAKER: It's like detox.
JAMES MULCAHY: Yeah,
you get detoxed.
GINA HOMOLKA: Is it
like a long-term thing?
JAMES MULCAHY: You could
like shave tumeric over it.
No, people are just replacing
their morning or afternoon
coffee with bone broth.
GINA HOMOLKA: OK.
It's kind of like having a soup.
JAMES MULCAHY: It's very trendy.
Zagat.com, everyone.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
It's like juicing.
GINA HOMOLKA: OK.
JAMES MULCAHY: Well, jucing--
GINA HOMOLKA: It's like a
savory type of juice, right?
Yeah.
Bone juice.
JAMES MULCAHY:
Hot, savory juice.
FEMALE SPEAKER: There may be a
cookbook coming December 2015,
all about--
JAMES MULCAHY: See, they
know about bone broth.
GINA HOMOLKA: They know.
See, they know.
JAMES MULCAHY: So then bone
broth maybe it's very new.
What about juice cleanse?
Every time I always
have a friend who's
trying to start to lose
weight, juice cleanse.
They're like oh, I'm
on seven day cleanse.
I'm like seven days?
Are you mad?
GINA HOMOLKA: I personally
don't do cleanses.
I get stomach aches when
I drink too much juice,
so it doesn't work for me.
I don't do cleanses.
If I feel like I put on weight,
I'll just get back on track
and do portion control and go
to the gym and lose it again.
JAMES MULCAHY: So you have
your moments when you--
GINA HOMOLKA: I do.
I mean I had two children.
You have your moments.
You go on vacation, you
eat too much that week.
I always have those moments.
It's why I started the blog.
As you get older, your
metabolism slows down.
So yes, absolutely,
I have those moments.
JAMES MULCAHY: So
don't get discouraged
if you fall off a little bit.
GINA HOMOLKA: Oh no.
I mean I don't beat myself up.
I just say, all right, today
I'm starting all over again.
Today's day one.
I'm not going to
think about yesterday.
JAMES MULCAHY: OK.
Butter coffee.
Have you heard of this?
GINA HOMOLKA: No.
JAMES MULCAHY: Have you
guys heard of butter coffee?
I've personally think it's nuts.
GINA HOMOLKA: What is it?
JAMES MULCAHY: It's basically
coffee with butter in it.
You drink it in the
morning and you're
supposed to just have that
and then you go to dinner.
But it gets you through the
day because it gives you
this illusion of fullness.
GINA HOMOLKA: Wow.
I don't think that would
be good for my cholesterol.
JAMES MULCAHY:
[LAUGH] I guess not.
It's kind of a crash
diet thing right now.
You Google it, you'll
find it's pretty nuts.
GINA HOMOLKA: OK.
Yeah, I'm not familiar.
Is there a book
coming out? [LAUGH]
JAMES MULCAHY: No.
Probably--
FEMALE SPEAKER: It's
called "Bulletproof."
JAMES MULCAHY: "Bulletproof."
GINA HOMOLKA: "Bulletproof."
JAMES MULCAHY: Yeah.
They serve it-- I've actually
seen it served at the gym,
like they have a butter coffee
at their little juice bar.
And like this can't be right.
GINA HOMOLKA: Strange.
JAMES MULCAHY: Like it's weird.
Let's see, how are
we doing on time?
I think we're-- well, no,
we're doing pretty well.
So what's next for you?
Is it you've done the
blog, you've done the book.
TV?
Are you going to be
the next Rachel Ray?
GINA HOMOLKA: I don't know.
JAMES MULCAHY: Are you
going to do some web series?
Where do you see this going?
GINA HOMOLKA: You know
I never really saw--
like seven years
ago I didn't know
that I was going to have a book
deal or make this a career.
So you just don't
know the future.
Like I can't even
predict what's going
to happen seven years from now.
But right now there's nothing
in the works for TV or video.
Perhaps when I
have my new kitchen
I want to try to start doing
some more video in my kitchen.
And maybe a second book.
JAMES MULCAHY: Oh.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Stay tuned.
JAMES MULCAHY: Stay tuned.
That's a good little
foreshadowing.
Do you think the blog
is going to still--
the blog as an idea, is it still
going to have relevance in four
or five years, or do you
think people are moving more
onto social media?
GINA HOMOLKA: Yeah, I'm
not-- it's hard to say.
I feel like social media works
hand in hand with the blog.
So I'm not sure.
I mean things are
always changing,
so it's hard to predict.
JAMES MULCAHY: People
are always going
to want to learn how to
lose weight and learn
how to cook better
for themselves
and change their lifestyles.
GINA HOMOLKA:
Right, right, right.
Absolutely.
I hope it doesn't go away
because I actually really enjoy
doing it.
JAMES MULCAHY: Yeah, it's
an evergreen business.
I mean like we were saying
it's a lifelong commitment.
GINA HOMOLKA: Right, it is.
JAMES MULCAHY: So
you're always going
to need that next new recipe.
GINA HOMOLKA: Yeah, exactly.
JAMES MULCAHY: And
then so book, blog.
What else?
I mean do you see yourself
ever stopping doing this?
GINA HOMOLKA: No, I don't.
I know.
People talk about
well, one day maybe you
could sell Skinnytaste
and you could, you know.
And I'm like no, I don't
want to stop doing this.
I love doing this.
So I can't see that right now.
I mean maybe one day
my daughter will--
I'll pass it onto my daughter.
Who knows?
Yeah.
But I love doing this.
I don't have
intentions on stopping.
JAMES MULCAHY: Yeah.
I mean here we are
on the Google stage.
GINA HOMOLKA: Exactly.
JAMES MULCAHY: That means
things are going pretty well.
GINA HOMOLKA: I would not
have gotten this opportunity
if I was still a retoucher.
[LAUGH] I've had amazing
opportunities with this blog
that I could have
never dreamed of.
JAMES MULCAHY: Maybe with
Skinnytaste line of food
one day?
GINA HOMOLKA: You
know, you never know.
Something like that could
be something-- selling
something, frozen dishes
that are mine would be fun.
JAMES MULCAHY: Yeah, I
think the frozen dishes
you see probably these
days are-- the recipes are
a little boring still, I think.
GINA HOMOLKA: Yeah.
JAMES MULCAHY: It's
a little cardboardy
like you were saying.
GINA HOMOLKA: Right.
I mean I already know what
recipes people like on my site.
And if perhaps they
don't want to cook it,
maybe I could offer it
frozen in the frozen section.
So if anyone's
listening-- [LAUGH]
JAMES MULCAHY: Now that you've
kind of developed a following
and you have this
book, do you get
to meet these people in
person that are your followers
and have really been
impacted by this?
GINA HOMOLKA: Yeah.
So now that the book came out,
I went on a few book signings
and I was able to
meet face-to-face
a lot of people that follow me.
And it was great
because a lot of them
brought pictures of their before
and after they lost weight,
and they showed me what
they looked like before.
And it's just so great to see
them and meet them in person,
and how they're regular people
and they're so grateful.
So it's been such
a great experience.
JAMES MULCAHY:
That's a good segue
to just mention that you're
going to be signing books
in the back after the talk.
So if anyone wants their books
to be signed, you can go say hi
when we're done here.
GINA HOMOLKA: Perfect.
JAMES MULCAHY: I'm just curious
to say the other craze I
was going to ask
you about, I think
there's a lot of debate
around "The Biggest Loser"
and that sort of thing.
These kind of binge
and purge shows.
Do you have any take on that?
GINA HOMOLKA: I don't really
watch "The Biggest Loser."
So no, I don't really.
I mean I know it
works for people.
It's pretty intense.
So I don't know.
If it's working for them.
JAMES MULCAHY: Yeah.
Stick to the butter coffee.
GINA HOMOLKA: Yeah.
JAMES MULCAHY: That's
probably a better [INAUDIBLE].
GINA HOMOLKA: Exactly.
JAMES MULCAHY: Cool.
I think we're winding
down, and we're
going to leave some time
for questions if anyone has
Q&A in the next few minutes.
There's a few
microphones on each side,
if anyone wants
to chat with Gina.
Someone's got to
have a question.
Here we go.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Gina.
My name is Andrea.
Nice to meet you.
GINA HOMOLKA: Nice to meet you.
AUDIENCE: I love your cookbook.
I make your Mediterranean
quinoa salad once a week.
GINA HOMOLKA: Awesome.
AUDIENCE: So yeah,
it never gets old.
Just had a question for
you about sponsored posts.
I know that you don't
do them too frequently,
but I'm curious if there's
any one product in particular
of all the ones you've worked
with that you would really
recommend getting for
someone who's super busy
and doesn't have much time.
GINA HOMOLKA: Yeah, I don't
do a lot of sponsored posts
because I just get a lot
of backlash when I do.
For some reason people
get really angry at me,
and they tell me in the
comments I can't believe
you got paid for this recipe.
I don't know why they
get so mad because it's
free-- the blog is free.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GINA HOMOLKA: Yeah.
But I also will only really
use a brand that I really love.
So I'm working with
Harry and David.
They have amazing pears.
It's easy.
I did-- for the Potato
Board, which it's potatoes,
so you can't go wrong with that.
I was working with
Almond Breeze.
As far as-- I'm trying
to think who else.
Oh, I work with DeLallo pasta.
DeLallo is amazing.
They have the best
tasting whole wheat pasta.
So if you could get
your hands on that.
We hate whole wheat
pasta at my house.
So when I first tried
it, my husband's
like this is not whole wheat.
And I was like it is.
He's like they're lying.
I'm like they're not.
Look, the ingredients
say whole wheat.
Like it's whole wheat.
So I would say DeLallo's
whole wheat pasta's amazing.
And I'm starting to
see it everywhere.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
GINA HOMOLKA: Sure.
JAMES MULCAHY: Let's
see, any other questions?
I think it's interesting you
mentioned quinoa, these very
trendy ingredients these days.
Are there a few of those
that you would like,
or fans of like the quinoa.
I see grain bowls
are becoming a thing.
Have you seen that?
GINA HOMOLKA: They are.
I like all those bowls.
Yeah, quinoa used to be fancy.
I feel like now
it's so mainstream.
Farro is one of those
things that you can't always
find in the supermarket.
So I feel like a lot of things
that aren't easy to buy,
I guess are fancy.
Chia-- I love using Chia.
Chia pudding.
JAMES MULCAHY: Chia.
OK, I don't know if
I've ever had chia.
GINA HOMOLKA: Yeah, it
expands when it's in liquid.
So if you leave
it overnight, like
I have a vanilla chia pudding.
It's so good.
Like it has this
strange texture,
so it's not for everybody.
But it gets a little
gelatinous, but it fills you up
and it has lots of omegas.
JAMES MULCAHY: Do you
have any predictions
as to what the next kind of
big ingredient's going to be?
GINA HOMOLKA: I don't.
JAMES MULCAHY: Other
than bone broth?
GINA HOMOLKA: I mean Brussels
sprouts are really big
right now, so maybe
more Brussels sprouts.
JAMES MULCAHY: More
Brussels sprouts.
Isn't it amazing, I was
a kid and I hated them.
GINA HOMOLKA: I know.
JAMES MULCAHY: And everyone
just loves them now.
GINA HOMOLKA: Everybody
was cooking them wrong.
JAMES MULCAHY: Yeah.
GINA HOMOLKA: Yeah.
JAMES MULCAHY: Yup, we
have a question here.
AUDIENCE: With regards
to the pasta dishes,
have you tried swapping
out for quinoa pasta,
because we seem to actually
really love that in our house.
GINA HOMOLKA: I
love quinoa pasta.
Yeah, I think it was
Ancient Grains I think
was the brand that I tried.
Because my aunt is
now gluten-free,
so I had to start trying
gluten-free brands.
So experimenting
I've learned which
ones are better than others.
But the quinoa
pasta's wonderful.
Tastes great.
Whole grain.
AUDIENCE: So your recipes then
you could probably swap out--
GINA HOMOLKA: Oh, absolutely.
AUDIENCE: OK.
GINA HOMOLKA: Absolutely.
JAMES MULCAHY: How do you modify
your recipes for gluten-free--
your gluten-free friends?
GINA HOMOLKA: So anything
that can be modified, I always
tell people how.
So if it's made
with soy sauce I'll
tell them to use
gluten-free Tamari.
If it's flower I'll
tell them to use
all-purpose gluten-free
flour in place, because I
have tested them and they work.
So I usually in every
recipe, even in the book,
I always talk about how to
make something gluten-free.
JAMES MULCAHY: Do
you have a question?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
So I just bought a zucchini
spiralizer the other week
and I love it.
But how do you
make the zucchini--
how do you get all
the water out of it?
Because I found that
after sauteing it,
it gets a little watery.
How do you work that?
GINA HOMOLKA: When I make
the spiralized zucchini,
I just cook it for about
a minute and a half.
After that I feel like
it starts getting watery.
So I will cook it for
a minute and a half,
remove it from the pot because
it'll still keep cooking,
and serve it right away.
So it's still a little
al dente kind of,
and it eliminates
that sogginess.
Also, I do some Asian dishes
that are cooked in a sauce.
So I'll make my
sauce not as thick,
like knowing that the zucchini's
going to add water to it.
So I'll cook it in the
sauce the last two minutes,
and it's going to kind of
bring everything together.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] too long.
GINA HOMOLKA: Yeah.
I know.
That's usually what happens
when you first start.
Also using a thicker
setting because it
comes with different settings.
It's better.
The thicker setting is better
because it's not as thin
so it doesn't melt away.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
GINA HOMOLKA: Yeah, sure.
JAMES MULCAHY: Are there any
food that you just won't eat?
GINA HOMOLKA: I won't
eat kidneys or liver.
And I say that because
I grew up with my mom
cooking that at times.
And I don't like Lima beans.
JAMES MULCAHY: Lima beans, OK.
Maybe Lima bean's going
to be the next Brussels
sprout though--
GINA HOMOLKA: Maybe.
JAMES MULCAHY: --and
make a comeback.
GINA HOMOLKA: I'll
have to figure out
a way, some kind of Lima
bean hummus or something.
That might work.
JAMES MULCAHY: Not too bad.
GINA HOMOLKA: Yeah.
JAMES MULCAHY: Let's
see, any other questions?
AUDIENCE: I have one, but
should I just yell out loud?
JAMES MULCAHY: You can yell.
We can hear you.
I'll repeat it.
AUDIENCE: I can't
get cauliflower crust
right for pizza, which is
one of my favorite dishes.
I try to lighten it up.
It's just a soggy mess.
So any tips?
GINA HOMOLKA: Yeah, I don't
have a cauliflower crust
pizza on my site,
because I remember
having the same issues.
Like if it requires so much
cheese that it's low carb,
but it's full of fat.
There's so much
cheese, you're almost
having like a cheese crust.
AUDIENCE: Cheese
on top of cheese.
GINA HOMOLKA: Exactly.
So that's why I never used it
because it was like when I did
the calories it was still high.
It was just not carbs.
Yeah.
I felt like it was
a lot of cheese.
I actually tried it with
spaghetti squash and it worked.
It was good with spaghetti
squash instead of cauliflower.
And maybe I have to keep
experimenting with that
and see if I could
perfect that one.
JAMES MULCAHY: Something
we notice at Zagat,
actually, is cauliflower's the
trendy ingredient of the moment
right now.
GINA HOMOLKA: Great.
JAMES MULCAHY:
And a lot of chefs
are substituting it for meat
and making steaks and using it
as a vessel for flavor.
Are you cauliflower fans?
GINA HOMOLKA: Oh yeah.
I have Buffalo cauliflower
that is instead of chicken,
it's cauliflower.
It's super popular
and people love it.
It's amazing how
popular cauliflower is.
I make a cauliflower rice, like
a fried rice instead of rice.
I use cauliflower in
place of everything.
I love cauliflower.
My husband hates it.
So when he likes it, I
know I did a good job.
JAMES MULCAHY: It's
very versatile, right.
GINA HOMOLKA: I love it.
JAMES MULCAHY: It
can do everything.
GINA HOMOLKA: Yeah.
I have cauliflower steaks,
and in the target version
of the cookbook they have
an exclusive version.
JAMES MULCAHY: Oh, cool.
GINA HOMOLKA: So yeah.
JAMES MULCAHY: Cool.
What else?
We got one in the back?
AUDIENCE: What is
your favorite recipe?
GINA HOMOLKA: In the book or?
AUDIENCE: Or on the blog.
GINA HOMOLKA: That's such a
hard question all the time.
It depends on the
day of the week.
My kids love the Picadillo.
I mean I make that
probably every two weeks.
I love in the book
the Zucchini Lasagna.
It tastes just like
lasagna, but it
has zucchini instead of pasta.
It's really good.
That would probably be-- or
the Buttermilk Fried Chicken.
I love fried chicken, so easy.
JAMES MULCAHY: How do
you make that healthy?
GINA HOMOLKA: I remove the skin.
I soak it overnight
in buttermilk,
so it has all the flavor like
with herbs and lemon juice.
And then I put a
crispy crust on top,
and then bake it at a
really high temperature
and it still tastes
like fried chicken.
JAMES MULCAHY: That's what
we had upstairs today, right?
GINA HOMOLKA: Yeah.
It has all the great flavor,
just without the skin
and without the frying.
And without the mess.
Frying is messy,
so baking's easy.
JAMES MULCAHY: I
love those recipes
that have the quotes around
it, like "fried" chicken.
So that means good for me.
GINA HOMOLKA: Right.
I have lots of those.
JAMES MULCAHY: I can eat that.
Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
What else?
No more questions?
Quinoa.
[LAUGHTER]
Celery?
GINA HOMOLKA: Let's think
of a trendy ingredient
that people aren't using.
My zucchini noodles
are super popular.
The Zoodles I call them.
JAMES MULCAHY: Zoodles.
GINA HOMOLKA: Yeah.
My husband names everything.
When I do spaghetti squash,
he calls it Squashta.
And I was like I love that.
So he's just really
quick with it,
so he comes up with
these one line names,
and I'm like I'm using that.
So yeah, Squashta,
spaghetti squash.
JAMES MULCAHY: So people could
come and see this on your blog.
How often do you
publish these days?
GINA HOMOLKA: I do
about three days a week.
JAMES MULCAHY: Three
days a week, OK.
GINA HOMOLKA: Sometimes four.
JAMES MULCAHY: Cookbook
is out, but the blog
is still up and running.
GINA HOMOLKA: Yeah.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
I never stopped, even when
I was doing the cookbook
I kept posting new recipes.
JAMES MULCAHY: Fingers
are going to fall off
from all that typing.
I think familiar feeling
to all of us Googlers.
GINA HOMOLKA: Well, yeah, yeah.
I mean I don't
really write a lot.
It's mostly photo, photo,
recipe, and just a small blurb
about my experience making it.
JAMES MULCAHY: Cool.
I think I'm going to
leave a little extra time,
and if no one has
any other questions.
So you can all say hi
to Gina in the back
and get your cookbook signed.
And definitely check out
her blog, Skinnytaste.com
and get some recipes.
I'm going to go really
eat healthy after this.
GINA HOMOLKA: Good.
JAMES MULCAHY: I'm
not going to lie.
I'm going to look for the
famous quotes around it.
GINA HOMOLKA: Maybe I
inspired one person.
JAMES MULCAHY: I know.
Like mmm.
Cool.
Thank you so much, Gina--
GINA HOMOLKA: Thank you
so mu for having me.
JAMES MULCAHY: for
hanging out with us today.
GINA HOMOLKA: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]